hello Wolfgang there are 22 days left
until Avengers infinity war comes out
and with all these trailers introducing
us to the mad Titan Thanos we're
starting to get a little concern for the
Avengers whether they can defeat him or
not but fear not there is still hope for
the Avengers because in the comics
Thanos has actually defeated many times
so today we'll be going over just a few
people who have defeated Thanos and the
ways that they've done it before we get
started don't forget to subscribe to my
channel the way you do it is you click
that little red subscribe button down
there now we'll be back what I just said
no that's the button it will kill
everyone also if you're not here for any
spoilers I'm not sure if any of this
will actually be in the movie so bye
disclaimer there are many ways that
Thanos is defeated in the comics and
today I will only be talking about a few
of them the first one that we'll be
talking about today is spider-man and
Hellcat I kind of threw this in here as
a joke because it's nothing like the
Thanos that we know in the MCU right now
the best part about this comic is Thanos
has a Thanos copter that's right a
Thanos copter and then he proceeds to
fight spider-man and Hellcat and what
she loses and then is taken away in
handcuffs I don't think it'll be so easy
for the Avengers to just put Dana's and
handcuffs and walk away but we'll see
next is Adam warlock Adam warlock turned
stano's into stone and then shatters him
we may see some variation of this in the
MCU because in guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 after the end credits scene we are
introduced to Adam warlock which means
he is now in the MCU will he be making
an appearance in Avengers 4 I certainly
hope so he's one of my favorite
characters and the Avengers will
certainly need him next to defeat the
mad Titan is Thane Fane is actually
Thanos a son this is something that we
could see pop up in Avengers infinity
war or Avengers 4 the Russo brothers
have stated that fans have no clue what
the actual plot of Avengers infinity war
is there's many reasons Thanos could be
out to rebalance the universe but let's
not cut out his son Thane in the comics
The Avengers are getting crushed by
Thanos and just before it's all about
and thane comes and saves them trapping
thanos in a living dead sort of amber
prison I can see the Avengers getting
their butts whooped by Thanos and
Avengers infinity war so maybe Thane is
the savior that they need next is Thor
that's right the mighty thor has
defeated Thanos well a clone of Thanos
yes
in the comics there is a Thanos clone
and Thor goes up against him and defeats
him this is no easy defeat because this
clone is pretty much exactly like Thanos
how does Thor defeat him you ask well he
takes the mighty me linear and hammers
him to death that's right he just wails
on him with the hammer until he dies I
personally would love to see Thor go to
town on Tanis with his new hammer
Stormbreaker until he defeats him but
seeing as how the Thanos in the MCU is
the actual Thanos I don't think it'll be
that easy for Thor another person who
have killed Thanos is the Hulk
well zombie Hulk yep there is a comic
where the Hulk is a zombie and actually
Thanos is a zombie as well pretty much
everyone zombies granted I just threw
this in here for fun because I think
it's cool but it's worthy to note that
the Hulk gets very annoyed with Thanos
and just straight-up Rams both of his
fists through his head killing him
instantly
I don't think there'll be any zombies
and infinity war or Avengers 4 but I do
think it would be pretty cool to see the
Hulk smash fantastis face in next is the
Avengers last the guardians of the
galaxy this is what I'm here to see
people in the comics you basically see
Thor and the guardians of the galaxy
beating the snot out of Thanos they
fight him until they pummel him into
submission I really hope that this is a
scene in Avengers infinity war or
Avengers for another person to defeat
Thanos is Captain Marvel that's Captain
Marvel not Captain Marvel and this comic
Thanos had a Cosmic Cube which is where
he got his immense power from Captain
Marvel with the help of Drax and mantas
managed to get the cube away from Thanos
which then allowed them to defeat him we
know that Captain Marvel is making an
appearance in Avengers infinity war and
most likely Avengers 4 I wonder if
she'll bring Marvel with her next is
Deadpool
kind of lonesome back here I know you're
thinking well deadpool can't really die
so it makes sense that he could defeat
Thanos but he actually defeats him in a
way that you really wouldn't guess if
you're not too familiar with dantos just
note that he's desperately in love with
death not killing but I'm sure he is in
love with that as well but the actual
lady death Deadpool and Thanos start
fighting in which Stannis throws
Deadpool into eternity when flying
through eternity
Deadpool meets the avatar of eternity
the avatar of eternity then gives
Deadpool powers turning him in to
Captain universe
Deadpool then takes on the avatar of
eternity and universe and goes back to
fight Thanos once he goes back and
starts fighting him he doesn't beat him
with sheer power he actually starts
talking to him during the middle of the
fight in which he says you serve life
just the same lady death / here's what
Deadpool said to Thanos and takes time
and carefully considers what was said
lady death
obviously not liking life just gets up
and leaves
Thanos then can't take the fact that
death left him because he's desperate in
love with her and then he explodes yeah
he just explodes
we'll see if we see in the movie you
never know and I'm after someone on my
naughty list and the last person who
defeats Thanos who I'll be talking about
today is Drax the destroyer
Drax defeats Thanos in a particular way
by punching a hole right through his
chest and ripping out his heart but
seeing as how Drax in the guardians of
the galaxy couldn't even take on Ronan
and Thanos being a lot stronger than
Ronan is I don't think that'll be
happening in Avengers infinity war so
those are just a few people who have
defeated Thanos in the comics what's
your favorite way Thanos gets defeated
in the comics and do you think any of
these are possible for Avengers infinity
war let me know your thoughts in the
comments below and be sure to like this
video and don't forget to subscribe and
give that little red button another try
try again
mm-hmm uh-huh thank you so much for
watching
woof woof